and finally go Falcons yeah man the
Falcons for the first time in a long
time I really care who wins the Super
Bowl and I have a fierce love of the
Atlanta Falcons because I'm from Atlanta
oh wait I'm not I'm from New Jersey I
could give a [ __ ] about Atlanta but the
Falcons are playing a team where the
owner the coach and the star quarterback
all love and support Donald Trump so I'd
really like for them to lose by a score
of a million [ __ ] thousand and you
love it when he drives us crazy okay and
that in microcosm is what Donald Trump
has done to me to us all he's made us
into that campus nut who can't buy a
chicken sandwich without making it
political he's made me love the Atlanta
Falcons
that's like saying your favorite boxer
is Mickey Rourke
it's like saying your favorite singer is
Ryan Gosling he can't sing
but I don't care
here's what I'm going to look like on
Sunday because I love the Falcon I love
their running back what did they and the
guy who catches the ball but mostly I
love them because Tom Brady was one of
the first to display a make America
great again hat
you know because America has been so
tough on Tom so perfect and and back
when tom was asked if he thought Trump
would be President he said I hope so
that would be great
hey Tom [ __ ] you you're a great
quarterback in your political instincts
suck coach Bill Belichick loves Trump so
much he sent him a fan letter during the
campaign which read you have dealt with
an unbelievably slanted and negative
media have come out beautifully your
leadership is amazing the toughness and
perseverance you have displayed over the
past year is remarkable
wow that's some serious blood licking
coach let me give you some advice to the
big game [ __ ] you Bella
[Applause]
[ __ ] you and your deflated balls you
joyless cheating [ __ ]
you see what sorrows represent to me I
used to be pretty eloquent now I'm just
screaming [ __ ] you if they're anything
this man can't ruin he took something
beautiful again
we're millionaires give each other brain
damage and made it tawdry and cheap even
worse every time he attends a sporting
event his hair does the weave I'm in the
way look I don't want to make everything
political but that's where we're headed
athletes are refusing to stay at Trump
hotels people are unfriending each other
on Facebook siblings have stopped
talking to one another which makes it
hard to get laid in the south
[Applause]
there are even reports that some hookers
won't pee on you until you assured them
it's not a Trump thing one member of the
l.l.bean family supported Trump and now
we're all supposed to boycott l.l.bean
which is not hard for me I've been
boycotting l.l.bean my entire life
because I don't like any store where
it's hard to tell the manikins from the
concert because they both got to stick
up their hand but what about lesbians
where are they supposed to shop now to
look like a lumberjack you know in 1960
only five percent of Americans had a
negative reaction to the idea of
marrying someone from a different
political party in 2010 that number shot
up to 40 percent for liberals bringing
home a Republican is the new guess who's
coming to dinner
only it's more like guess who's coming
to dinner and spending the whole meal
bitching about Mexican